do you feel like we do i mean you can't
go anywhere on a concert tour and not
play this song right no i would be
lynched yeah
i didn't get back on that stage is this
your signature song
i think that riff at the beginning is is
uh everybody knows that yeah yeah that
riff is what
all right that's it that one now is that
one that takes three seconds to write or
is that a little more difficult i was
rehearsing with the frampton's camel
band and we were going out to do our
first uh american tour to promote my
first solo record right and um so we
would jam i'd bring a tape recorder reel
to reel to each rehearsal just in case
we played something we liked in jamming
and so we were jamming and somewhere in
the
in the jam i played you know
that whole riff and then when we
finished the jam the band all looked at
me and said wind it back about 45
seconds wow because we i didn't i don't
know you didn't well you weren't even
paying attention no right you were just
just just loading so i like whoa and
then everyone said can we work on that
let's write let's write us something
around that yeah so we worked on the
whole thing and then the night before i
came up with
[Music]
um that seems so simple yet it always
gives me the chills when i get it
i wrote that and i uh i can't remember
whether i wrote do you feel like i do
lyrically the night that the night
before or actually
i was working on a hangover or that day
of the rehearsal this song is about a
hangover it is a hat i always heard that
and i said oh that can't be it it's got
to be deeper than that yeah it is you
were just filthy drunk and you woke up
and you went oh do you feel like i do
yeah and do you say oh that sounds like
a song lyric yeah i sort of wrote that
down because it's one of those mornings
when i still smoke cigarettes which
and i woke up with the full
mountainous ashtray of butts you know
and and a glass of some sort of whiskey
or bread oh my god and you wake up and
you smell all that you go
yeah
and it's like do you feel like i do yeah
well since we're having so much fun
would you mind one last time one one
final song do you feel like we do and
we'll all think about that massive
hangover you had that day all right here
we go
okay
one
two
one two three four
[Music]
do
so
woke up this morning with a wine glass
in my hand
who's wine what the wine where the hell
did i die
must have been a dream
i don't believe where i've been
come on
[Music]
well my friend got busted just the other
day
they said
don't walk away
drove into a taxi bent the boot that's
the bag
had to play some music
otherwise he'd
you
you
feel like i
[Music]
do you
you
dude
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
you
[Music]
champagne for breakfast and a sherman in
my hand
i got a black top blue tails
never fails
must have been a dream
i don't believe where i've been
so come
on we're gonna do it again
[Music]
do you feel
like
[Music]
go
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
look at you two congratulating each
other
now is that song the most joyous song
for you to play because you're smiling
at each other through the whole thing
when you guys start laughing at each
other it's because you did something you
both like and you hear something new is
that what's happening exactly you're
vibing as musicians yes and as many
times as maybe you've rehearsed that or
played that together there's something
new that happens each time we never we
try to never play the same solos twice
it's always i i can't learn my own solos
even right so something new just
happened there we heard something one of
a kind
and it's never lost on me that i'm
sitting next to peter frampton yeah i
tell you playing this